m
dans le cadre du 200e anniversaire de la
loge l'amitié s'est déroulé le
vernissage de l'exposition les francs
maçons et la mère de la loge ok aux
archives départementales de la réunion
ce samedi 14 mai on accueille une
exposition qui a été conçue par le musée
de la franc maçonnerie est présentée à
paris en 2015 et on a réutilisé le texte
des panneaux du catalogue de
l'exposition pour la présenter elle a
décliné aussi légalement avec un focus
sur le développement de la franc
maçonnerie dans dans l'océan indien
et pour donner un peu à voir toute la
symbolique maçonnique
elle a été complétée par des détenus et
des objets qui proviennent de la loge de
l'amitié et de la collection personnelle
de daniel et aussi quelques documents
des archives départementales sur l'éloge
de la reine un vernissage qui s'est
déroulé en présence de daniel keller
grand maître du grand orient de france
en visite sur l'île la franc maçonnerie
une société de pensée qui a plus de deux
siècles d'existence cette exposition et
d'un moment important pour nous pour
nous pour le vent de l'enfance parce que
elle participe d'une démarche
d'extériorisation crirc est important
que les francs-maçons montrent ce qu'ils
font ce qu'ils sont et quel meilleur
moyen que de le montrer à travers ces
pages du soir
une exposition qui permet à tous de
découvrir l'histoire de la
franc-maçonnerie encore très peu connus
aujourd'hui on a cette opportunité
d'avoir aux archives départementales
cette exposition les francs maçons et la
mer et ça donne la possibilité
à tout à chacun de venir aux archives
départementales et de découvrir cette
belle exposition est de comprendre ce
que c'est que la franc maçonnerie et
faire le rapprochement avec notre
histoire notre patrimoine institutions à
caractère philosophique siège d'une
sociabilité fraternelle forte la
maçonnerie et héritière d'humanisme et
de tolérance des valeurs importantes
pour la présidente du département
nassimah dindar
il apprend maçonnerie c'est aussi
beaucoup interrogé sur
la place de l'homme
sa réflexion son rapport à lui-même
son rapport aux autres pour vivre
ensemble et au moment où on sent bien
dans la société française
voire européennes et mondiales un repli
identitaire
les communautés où les groupes sont
constitués avec
une appartenance ou pas les jeunes
en attente de cette appartenance là je
crois que la franc maçonnerie un rôle
encore capital à jouer l'exposition sera
visible jusqu'au 2 septembre 2016 aux
archives départementales de la réunion à
champ fleuri